millions of people were transfixed by
Bird Box a horror flick that channeled
the fear of the Unseen it was only a
matter of time before a sequel would
appear on the horizon here's what we
know about Bird Box Barcelona
the original Bird Box was released on
Netflix in December 2018 and it proved
to be an overwhelming success as such a
sequel was announced in 2021 though
information at that time was sparse
deadline reported production of this
unnamed Bird Box sequel would begin
later that year but the publication did
note that the movie would be set in
Spain they also added that bird box was
watched by 89 million households in the
first month of its release which was one
of the biggest successes Netflix had at
that point luckily the release date of
bird box Barcelona is July 14 2023. this
is a little over two months after the
trailer's release so fans of horror and
monsters won't have to wait long to get
an extra dose it's also a warning to be
prepared for the inevitable Deluge of
memes jokes and spoilers because if the
sequel is anything like the original
Netflix will have another hit on its
hand
much like its predecessor Bird Box
Barcelona is all about how Earth was
devastated after the appearance of
unknown and mysterious entities these
beings cannot be viewed in any shape or
form because seeing them causes people
to lose their minds and self-destruct in
the first bird box there are some who
have seen the creatures live yet their
existence is marked by a frenzy to force
others to do the same open your eyes
Bird Box Barcelona is set in Europe so
audiences will get a chance to see how
another corner of the world deals with
these unknowable monsters you're not
worthy or not they come to the same
conclusion as those in Bird Box however
as illustrated by the original film
sometimes people can be even more
dangerous than monsters it will be
interesting to see how Bird Box
Barcelona brings something new to the
table every contact we have had with the
outside has brought us death it will
also be interesting to see if the
upcoming spin-off reveals more about the
monsters and the magnitude of their
destruction the early teasers suggest
that the creatures have continued their
Conquest since we last saw them this
could indicate that this installment
will be more grandiose than its
predecessor
the cast of bird box Barcelona features
some truly impressive Talent Georgina
Campbell Diego calva Mario Casas
Michelle Jenner Alejandra Howard and
Leonardo baraglia are just some of the
actors who are confirmed audiences May
recognize Campbell from our role in the
horror movie Barbarian or an episode of
Black Mirror likewise calva is probably
best recognized these days for the film
Babylon or Casas has a whole slew of
Spanish-speaking credits according to
the official synopsis of the movie The
Plot centers around Sebastian and his
young daughter Anna the duo must survive
in Barcelona after the creatures
featured in Bird Box wreak havoc on
their home the synopsis goes on to state
that the two fought in Alliance with
other survivors but as they seek a
sanctuary they encounter a threat more
dangerous even than the entities they
flee
off the first Bird Box movie is an
adaptation of Josh malderman's debut
novel of the same name which was
released through Echo Press in 2014 a
sequel called Mallory was released
through Delray books in 2020 and follows
a titular character and have two young
children as they set out to find more
survivors however the sequel novel
doesn't appear to have informed Bird Box
Barcelona nor there currently any plans
to adapt it as it stands the Spanish
language spin-off looks like an original
story from the minds of Alex pastor and
David pasta though malaman is credited
as a writer on the film it remains to be
seen if he had any further input on the
creative direction of bird box Barcelona
but it goes without saying that the
spin-off wouldn't exist without his core
ideas laying the groundwork
stay close
who's there
but maybe if malaman sees the movie on
Netflix it will inspire him to write
more stories set in this world which
might end up inspiring their own movies
someday in an interview with read more
Co malaman said that the success of the
first film coupled with seeing Bullock
bring Mallory to life inspired him to
return to the bird box universe so who
knows what will happen if the
barcelonian spin-off is a success
the original Bird Box was directed by
Susan beer and produced by Dylan Clark
Chris Morgan and Clayton Townsend
however the person in the director's
chair has changed the new movie will be
directed by David and Alex Pastor Bird
Box was based on the book of the same
name by Josh malaman and it seems as if
the pastors and malaman have writing
credits for Bird Box Barcelona having
the book's author contribute to the new
story means that bird box Barcelona will
stay very true to the first movie in
addition the pastors are probably best
known for their efforts in 2009's
carriers and 2015's selfless producer
Dylan Clark told deadline our world has
never been more interconnected to
explore the phenomenon that is Bird Box
was David and Alex Pastor following
people surviving in Barcelona it's a
timely opportunity to not only entertain
but also show how dependent we all are
to each other Chris Morgan made a
statement as well speaking about how the
new movie will carry on the legacy of
bird box in our new chapter our
incredible filmmakers Alex and David
pasta of all the expanding Bird Box in a
globally connected way that only Netflix
can deliver the result is an intense
unexpected Survival Story with familial
emotion and heart I can't wait for
audiences around the world to see the
surprising Mysteries that unfold on the
streets of Barcelona
of course you can't watch Bird Box
Barcelona without watching the movie
that started it all bird box came out in
2018 and dominated pop culture for quite
a while starring Sandra Bullock Bird Box
focuses on Mallory Hayes and her two
young children as they attempt to reach
a sanctuary from the insanity inducing
monsters in their travels the Hayes
family comes across allies and enemies
and it becomes immediately apparent that
trust is a valuable commodity in this
post-apocalyptic World while some of the
post-apocalyptic genre May focus on
man-made tragedies zombies or world
ending Wars Bird Box instead sees
Humanity tearing itself apart their
self-destruction doesn't come in the
form of infighting or Wars but from the
madness caused by the presence of the
monsters that roam the Earth Bird Box is
still available on Netflix and it's the
only place you can watch both movies
under no circumstance are you allowed to
take off your blindfold
Bird Box was rated R for all of the
things you'd expect from a tense horror
Thriller violence blood and even a few
curse words beyond the standard reasons
why I earned its rating though the
themes of Madness and self-harm are
Central to the story it means younger
audiences would likely have trouble
fully understanding the deepest subtext
that permeates the film keeping all of
that in mind it seems likely that the
follow-up will have the same rating for
similar reasons both movies deal with
the same subject matter so if anything
Bird Box Barcelona could be more intense
than his predecessor given how sequels
always seem to up the stakes from the
previous film so if Bird Box wasn't
suitable for kids then the new movie
would definitely be something parents
should avoid the teaser illustrates the
point extremely well that's one key
moment we see people fleeing Carnage or
hurting themselves for the horror of
onlookers the trailer then moves to a
news report from Europe where the same
Devastation is spreading across that
continent as well not exactly an ideal
bedtime story
Bird Box Barcelona isn't a direct sequel
to the 2018 film but it is set in the
same world as a terrifying Thriller it
seems the masterminds behind the first
feature want to keep expanding the world
of the first movie as well as explore
how different parts of the world have
been affected by the monster Invasion
while the franchises producers haven't
outright confirmed plans for more bird
box installments yet they have certainly
teased that more movies could see the
light of day in the future producer
Chris Morgan told Entertainment Weekly
Mallory's Journey was just the first
chapter of This Global apocalyptic event
as we were developing the original film
we often discuss what would be happening
at the same time in different countries
around the world given this information
it seems only natural that future movies
in the franchise will continue to
explore the devastation in other parts
of the World perhaps one day we'll see
how the monsters invaded countries like
Japan India or China what would a bird
box film set in Australia look like
could the island nation avoid the
catastrophe that has fallen on the rest
of the world our society is still
dealing with the Fallout of the kobit 19
pandemic using bird box as a way to
explore societal changes had emerged
after the end of that event could be
extremely fascinating furthermore
Netflix has a history of milking
franchises as evidenced by The Witcher
blood origin and Berlin a money Heist
spin-off so we shouldn't rule out the
possibility of more installments of bird
box the premise of the movie certainly
lends itself to franchise storytelling
and there are many horror fans out there
who love to see sequels and spin-offs
come to fruition
foreign